the og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to another
episode of the leia hill pan show today
we have a lot of hot topics that we are
bringing you but before i bring my
guests on i do want to let you know that
this podcast is sponsored by bitmex
bitmex is the og crypto derivatives
exchange that has now launched a spot
exchange for you to easily buy and sell
all your different crypto assets
especially in a bear market you need a
name that you can trust bitmex sets the
standard for reliability performance and
transparency and has of course proven
this through multiple cycles and has
really stood the test of time so right
now bitmex is celebrating the start of
its spot exchange with 1 million dollars
in usd prizes to give away to enter all
you need to do is trade the equivalent
of
250 so you could pick up some bitcoin
during the dip you can either enter up
to 25 times and one lucky winner will
win 500 000
in bitcoin so to enter and start buying
bitcoin and start your crypto journey
i'm gonna leave all of the links in the
description for you below so you can
sign up and enter and start joining
bitmex today also on this podcast as you
know we're having the conversations that
you're sort of not allowed to have and
nobody else is having so a massive thank
you to bitmex because without them we
wouldn't be able to bring you such
valuable content all right guys it's
time to do this joining me on the show
today is adam sosnick the host of the
sauce cast podcast and the co-host of
the very very majorly famous and
successful youtube channel valuetainment
adam welcome to the show how you doing
you nailed that intro there wonder great
job right i feel like it's a bit of a
mouthful but we got there at the end
yeah sometimes when your brain works so
fast you know the words don't come out i
stumble my words all the time because my
brain works so freaking fast but you
crushed it i like that so for those i
don't know who you are because obviously
i come from more of the crypto world um
you're a super interesting guy please
just explain briefly your background and
what you do at valuetainment sure um
well i'm uh born and raised in miami i'm
a former jack of all trades miami party
boy comedian
who in his early 20s just didn't know
what the hell was going on uh and then i
started seeing all my friends make tons
and tons of money
um this is around 2006 2007 right before
the financial crash uh in miami in real
estate and i was like all right i gotta
i gotta get involved something like i
can't just be the guy on people's couch
anymore so i transitioned into finance i
got a job as a cold caller for a
financial firm hedge fund
and um i'm i crushed it in that business
i'm a financial executive at uh vp of
sales at the same financial firm i
started in
06
and from there i transitioned into being
a host and co-host with valuetainment
i've known i've done business with
patrick david shout out to patrick um
for 10 years before he recruited me to
valuetainment um but really what like i
owe my success to is that i'm a master
networker so i've i'm just constantly
networking i'm just in the right
places right times talking to the right
people and uh and this is something that
i'm dealing with patrick on is that like
yeah i made it in money i made it in
finance i've made it in podcasting
valuetainment great great great what do
i owe my success to is just that i
understand social dynamics and i
understand networking so the power of
networking yeah so social dynamics is
interesting because i know you talk a
lot about that not just finance and
we're going to get to that but you said
you didn't really know what you're doing
in your 20s maybe a little bit your 30s
i don't know but what i do know is you
made a good call quite a few years ago
and you bought a lot of bitcoin
so how did you even hear about bitcoin
and may i ask what price did you buy at
sure i um i got to give a shout to
adrian one of the um
co-founders of ethernet nft platform um
[Music]
but i i was broke as [ __ ] at 25. so to
all the 25 year olds out there
like life's a marathon especially your
financial life as a marathon most people
do not start making real money into
their late 30s early 40s and so i went
from being what's wrong money by the way
just uh i'm saying you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year i mean
unlike
a baseline obviously you know there's
people that made millions and i'm saying
annual income right but um
i went from being
again a broke party boy miami i got paid
in drink tickets and fun times and you
know
clubs and women and that was great but i
would go home and sleep on like my
buddy's couch so in your early 20s i
actually actively encourage people to
just
[ __ ] about like just figure it out
figure out what you're into but most
importantly figure out what you're not
into like where do you not like i almost
went to law school thank god that i
did not end up in law school i just i
would have been a horrible lawyer i
don't like to read all that much
especially boring stuff
but um
i got a i was always good at because i
did stand up comedy i was always a
nightlife person so sales was always
going to be the avenue that i was going
to make money so i went and i got into
finance i what was your initial question
how did i get into that how'd you get
into bitcoin oh bitcoin so i i crushed
in finance over the course of 10 years i
made x amount of million dollars
and uh when i was 2 35 years old i was
going through a breakup with a british
girl no no offense to the brits out
there you're great you're lovely we're
still friends but i was like all right
i've got all this money i'm free i'm
single what the hell do i want to do
with my free time what i call chilling
so i've developed like the six step plan
to understanding your money right and
step six is when you are chilling
chilling is when you own your time you
don't have to wake up and run off to
work or do anything just what do you
want to do today it's your life right
most people when i ask them what do you
want to do if you're chilling i say if
you were chilling you had millions of
dollars in the bank whatever the number
is that whether it's a million 10
million 100 million dollars what would
you do with your free time if you were
quote unquote chilling
and everyone says the same three things
number one you want to travel
number two you want to
um pursue a passion number three you
want to give back and donate your time
and the last one that most people want
to do is leave a legacy whether that's
with your family whether that's
philanthropically whether that's with
the company like leave a legacy so i
said all right what's my challenge i've
already partied i'm from miami i've
already partied enough for 10 lifetimes
i've already traveled the world i've had
a good time now what the hell do i want
to do
and i started a show to teach
millennials basically how to save that
money
and i uh invested into starting up a
show much like you're doing here right
um
but i had some capital and this was
right around the time 2016 to answer
your question
uh i started hearing about bitcoin more
and more and more and more and my buddy
adrian was like yo bro like let me get
10 grand i was like for what he's like
for bitcoin man i'm like bitcoin bitty
bops crypto blockchain i didn't know
none of it i just called it bitty bops
and uh let me get 10 grand all right
fine whatever hey let me get another 10
grand i'm like alright cool this is your
best friend asking for money he's never
asked me for money and 50 grand later
i'm like all right what the [ __ ] is this
bitcoin thing but i trust him you asked
what price i got it at um what was the
price in 2016 2017 i don't was it before
the pump was it before the it was before
before before it hit 18 and then crashed
was that the number yeah yeah yeah okay
so before that okay so
with my background in finance because i
usually i'm a big stock investor that's
s p 500 index fund like you know dollar
cost averaging that's just very very
um
normal for me
um
and uh
bitcoin crashed and he's like so what do
you want you want to sell it i'm like no
that's not
how what you do with an asset class you
believe in you buy and hold and then i
found out it's not hold it's
huddle exactly right okay so then with
my show
i started basically the way i started my
show is i went around interviewing all
the financial advisors that i deal with
right so because i for my hedge fund i'm
basically a financial wholesaler i deal
with
um
estate planners financial advisors
insurance agents brokerages and they
come to me and for what my niche is
right but so i would go to all these
financial conferences and interview
the best of the best brightest minds in
finance insurance investments whatever
and then through adrian because he was
working with uh crypto trader on
cnbc yes with ran uh what's rand's last
name nuna rand
and uh he would get me access to all
these
bitcoin events and and
easily enough they were a lot of them
were in florida um so i would go to
these events and i would interview these
bitcoin enthusiasts and quite admittedly
i thought it was like it was weirdos and
this is
2017. it was not
you know it's still not that cool it's
still not it's much cooler now like
you're at the bitcoin conference here
like logic's performing steve aoki like
they're throwing banger concerts right
but then it was like weird fringe people
like forex people
you know i don't even know if they were
libertarians at that point i don't know
but it was very new
and admittedly i was like i'll go
because it's interesting but it's i was
i was almost
laughing i don't want to like be
disparaging but i was like i went to
film content i wasn't going because
these people are changing the world i do
have a different perspective on it now
because your perspective can change when
your information that you're um
digesting changes so
yeah that's when i learned about
kryptonite i remember i interviewed this
one lady
and she's like i left my man and i fell
in love with bitcoin and i'm all about
i'm like all right like she's just i was
like this lady is leaving her man
to go after bitcoin so that's when i
started realizing all right this is a
real thing
and then obviously during covid and we
saw what happened with bitcoin but yeah
i got involved in 2016-17
but not because i was a believer because
i believed in the person that was
pitching me
so you said you have a different
perspective now has that changed
well i mean if your perspective hasn't
changed since 2017 and it's 2022 like on
everything whether that's politics or
that business whether that's
relationships whether that's the economy
whether that's you know just the global
marketplace whether it's covet whether
it's china whether it's [ __ ] bitcoin
well what's your perspective on bitcoin
now well i think it's
again um if you believe in the asset
class you're there for the long term
so you know i just bought like i told
you i asked you the other day i'm like
should i buy bitcoin and you're like
yeah buy some and i asked you
where you thought the low mark would be
i thought you said like maybe like
15-ish potentially okay potentially so i
bought like three more bitcoin at 20. so
and i asked adrian um ethernet guy i was
like should i buy more because i'm just
sitting on cash here and uh he's like
hold off not not yet so um
i i i've i follow what the big boys do
and i remember when like tesla started
buying bitcoin elon musk and micro
strategies michael saylor who i've
interviewed and you know a lot of the
people that
were dabbling and dipping their toes
into bitcoin the number that i saw
was between three and eight percent so
the big boys i'm talking massive hedge
funds banks you know teslas of the world
three and eight percent of their cash
reserves so i'm i've employed that exact
same strategy so if i've got a hundred
grand i'll take you know three to eight
percent of it and pump that into bitcoin
so it all depends on what your
you know is palatable to you so let's
talk about those strategies you're the
finance guy you set up this podcast so
that you could help educate millennials
about finance so
in your opinion where do you think
people are going wrong when it comes to
money what don't they understand yeah i
mean i say this all the time is that we
all go to school we take the same boring
classes algebra biology chemistry
trigonometry i took wood shop zero
percent chance that i'm cutting wood in
my life
and but they don't teach you about
money they don't teach you money classes
they don't take you teach you money
management they don't teach you about
investing they don't teach you about the
stock market they don't teach you about
taxes they don't teach you about any of
the principles that you're going to need
when you're a grown up
and it's a part of it is because a
teacher who makes 40 50 grand a year
they don't know what the hell they're
doing they're teaching history or
algebra or calculus but there's no
classes like that so i've always i go to
schools and i speak at these schools and
i'm like show of hands if you guys
understand appreciation depreciation how
money works stock market and like you
have 10th graders 11th graders they're
like yeah i don't know what you're
talking about but those same kids know
about crypto these days though so that's
the difference crypto has basically
pierced through to be part of the pop
culture nomenclature that kids kind of
understand the problem
um and this is the the good and the bad
of bitcoin is that you don't start with
bitcoin
you need to start with like
understanding cash flow budgeting have a
game plan for your money getting out of
debt not getting into debt understanding
having cash reserves right most of
americans don't have 10 grand i tell
people to have 10 grand to your life
before you start trying to become a
millionaire right like there's levels to
this you go from a thousand to 10 000 to
100 000 to a millionaire you don't go
from a thousand dollars to a millionaire
like it's just not going to work out
well for you so crypto and crypto
bitcoin has done a great job in getting
people to like understand finance
but you know you gotta crawl before you
walk walk before you run run before you
run a marathon some people these days
especially young people just think that
it's easy you buy dogecoin and you're
overnight millionaire doesn't work like
that but what aren't people
understanding you said most people don't
have 10 grand to their name so why um
like in what way are they so financially
illiterate yeah i think people are
i almost said people are smart and then
i caught myself people some people are
smart most people are smart but if
there's a difference between book smart
going to school taking classes and
understanding that how money works
understand the difference between wants
and needs understanding what a basic
budget is right
one of the things i always say about
having a budget is like the only thing
worse than doing a monthly budget is not
doing a monthly budget right so if you
have 10 grand coming in every month
and you have 10 grand going out every
month you know it's not how much you
make it's how much you keep so um it's
a lot of so
this is what i'll give you this 50 of
money management is knowledge right i
understand i want to get out of debt i
want to make money i want to say i get
it but the other 50 is behavioral are
your actions following what your
knowledge is it's almost like yeah like
for instance
70 of americans are overweight whatever
it is
they know that they shouldn't have four
cheeseburgers for dinner they know that
they shouldn't get wasted and have pizza
right like i used to do back in the day
in south beach like yeah and i got fat
for a little bit like you know that you
need to work out so you know these
things just like with money you know you
need to save you no need to get off debt
you know that with your tax refund for
five grand you could either pump that
into a roth ira or go to [ __ ] mykonos
but your are your actions mirroring what
the knowledge tells you to do and most
people don't do that
so how do people get it right yeah
that's the million dollar question right
so i mean it comes with it comes with
having the knowledge base so if you just
don't know how to budget or how cash
flow works or what interest rates are
like yeah read a book there's like the
millionaire next door how to get rich
think and grow rich right there's
um you know the richest man in babylon
there's tons and tons of books that you
can read for knowledge but if you're not
you know performing what the knowledge
tells you to do
it's like how many people read exercise
books that's great you know how to do it
but are you
getting in the gym most people need a
kick in the ass and say
no don't go out saturday night bro
you're broke as [ __ ] stay in the house
like if you oh i do it i want to go out
i want to meet a girl it's like
yeah you know well if you do meet the
girl and you're broke
like how is that going to serve you so
are your is your knowledge aligned with
your actions most people don't have the
knowledge and certainly don't have the
actions to mirror what the knowledge
should tell them to do so it's a
learning curve it's a learning process
and the quicker you can learn it the
better off you'll be because life gets
more expensive as you go on your 30s are
more expensive than your 20s your 40s
are more expensive than your third
because you're going to grow up you've
got a mortgage you've got kids you've
got family life's only to get more
expensive so the quicker you can learn
basic financial lessons have a decent
foundation for your home your financial
home the better off you'll be in the
long run at 30 like i went from broke as
f at 25 to being a millionaire at 35
okay
did i do anything magical that would i
did i you know i didn't buy dogecoin and
just wish on a star i put in the work i
had work ethic i networked my ass off
okay i hung around the right people any
like if i had a
you know let's say i made 50 grand a
month because i've had some amazing
months where i've made hundreds of
thousands of dollars and i've had months
where i've made nothing but over the
course of time
if i made a hundred grand in a month
like the other day like this is a story
we tell in the podcast
um
i made 150 grand in april okay one month
and pat goes
patrickbetdavid goes what did you buy
and i go yeah i bought a new suit
because how much of that cost 500 bucks
because that's it i actually got some
white shirts at h m i spent like
probably like another 80 bucks so i
spent 580 bucks
versus i could have spent 50 grand i
could have gone to the club i could have
bought bottles i could have bought a
ridiculous car
ultimately who i am like i just realized
everyone's you know
we're all learning who we are every year
like if you're not adjusting and
learning i've realized that i'm a
minimalist who has become a millionaire
so i don't spend a lot of money on
myself when i do have like a girl in my
life i tend to spend a lot of money on
her because i don't really care like
i could buy uh oh [ __ ] i'm sorry you're
fine
what could you buy gideon um
i could have bought a rolex i but i
bought bitcoin okay i could have bought
um
a
ridiculous car i haven't had a car in 11
years
i'm like
i'm sort of redefining what it is to be
wealthy like again with the children
thing i like to own my time i don't i
don't i don't need like
luxury goods i don't need to have
ridiculous cars and chains
to tell me all right you're wealthy it's
like i look at my bank accounts like
life's going okay i'm very comfortable
in my own skin
and i feel like a lot of people
especially millennials you're familiar
with the acronym henry's no high earners
not rich yet millennials so 50 of
millennials are making 100 grand or more
a year are living paycheck to paycheck
that is the exact opposite of the stuff
that i condone right if you're making
100 a year live off 50 of it have a
roommate you're a millennial you're 28
years old whatever like don't grow up
too quick
and save that money right so that's like
my entire catchphrase to save that money
because
if you start saving now and start
investing now and hotel bitcoin now by
the time you're 40
you're chilling the rest of your life
the problem you ever hear what bernie
sanders says about
um
boomers no what did he say okay so i'll
do like a little bernie sanders
impression right there well like when he
was running for president not that i'm
bernie sanders advocate but i do think
he's um
quite humorous he goes do you understand
that 50 of baby boomers have zero save
for retirement zero
so you're gonna you know what happens if
you have zero save for retirement is
because people are living longer they
used to die at 65 that's why social
security kicks in at 62 or 65 you'd live
to 67 years it's like you have an
insurance plan for the government for
two three years okay now you live to 80
90 100 no problem you want to be on the
government plan for the next 30 40 years
not me so um the quicker you understand
that you're going to need money
way longer than you think the like
the biggest emphasis is understanding
the difference between your wants today
and your needs tomorrow so right now my
mom
who's you know doing healthy she's 71
years old she doesn't have money thank
god she has a successful son that pays
her bills straight up but a lot of
people are gonna be dealing with that
problem especially if your parents
haven't saved that money so um if your
parents haven't done it you're gonna
probably have to do it for them yeah
it's a sad reality um but i'm happy that
your mum has you that's great that's
important she sent her love by the way
oh thank you i'm not that i'm fair for
anything but there you go um okay so
the game is changing you've been in the
finance business for a while um you're
41 now you said so it's been a while so
how has the game changed and how do
people make money now is is it really
online is online the best way to start
earning for young people yeah well i
mean the barriers of entry have all been
taken down right so i say this all the
time that you know um you know in the
90s uh not that i was in finance in the
90s but i watched all those movies you
know boiler room wolf of wall street
which was you know obviously
10 years ago but based in the 90s all
those movies wall street
greed is good the whole thing if you
wanted to trade stock or even crypto for
that matter didn't exist but let's use
today's terms you would have to pick up
the phone one of your old school zack
morris phones shout out to the saved by
the bell watchers out there do you even
know what that is yes i watched okay
um rest in peace screech did he die oh
yeah when was it last year oh wow i had
no idea there you go sorry dustin
diamond i apologize
um but you'd have to pick up the phone
make a call to your stock broker or they
would cold call you you know like the
pink sleeps pink sheets that they talked
about in
uh wolf of wall street and you would
have to
negotiate what you wanted to spend in
the stock market with some shady guy on
the other side of the phone not that all
financial advisors are shady but this
was the reality of the 90s and this is
how jordan belford wolf of wall street
made all his money
by
scamming people
on the phone and employing hundreds and
hundreds of other people
to make calls on the phone but now that
person you don't need that person
anymore you could log on to a variety of
exchanges
and
just get online
yourself you know whether that's a
robo-advisor a fee based broker or
whether that's a you know bit max or any
of the crypto accounts out there
crypto.com or
uh f what is it f x bit max bit no okay
bitmaps it's only bitmaps i don't know
i'm naming other things clearly that's
the only thing that's going on
um but the bearer of entry is now gone
just like in media just like in social
media that's why valuetainment is so
successful we didn't have to wait around
for us to get plucked out by a network
you know cnbc or nbc or fox and say hey
you guys are great no we're just going
to start our own thing i mean just look
at you like you i know you're on media
networks but you can't count on that
unless you want to be a full-time media
network uh
pundit so you're just starting out so
the barrier entry is no longer there
crypto um
media
all that so
uh you don't need to go through the
typical channels so young people have an
amazing ability to
kind of use tech to their advantage so
have at it guys well what do you do if
you don't have any capital to start off
with um
you know you you can't invest in the
business whether it's you know hiring a
studio like this or whether it's um
hiring employees what do you do if you
don't have any capital i mean if you
don't have any capital what the hell can
you do i mean you have to work
people are scared of working these days
so you know since the pandemic how many
people were unemployed getting out of uh
just like copping out just yeah just
work ethic is a thing that
i don't know for whatever reason
is not is it frowned upon i mean you're
younger than me is work ethic frowned
upon these days like i had to work my uh
to get to the point of making going from
making my first year that i got involved
in finance i made five thousand dollars
in one year leia my next year i made a
hundred grand the year after that i made
250 the year after that i made 500 then
on and then but i started at five grand
why because i was dialing for dollars
like crazy i wasn't doing like the
jordan belford shady stuff because i'm
with the same firm five years later
we're great we're good finra approved
the whole thing
but you have to work yeah you know so
hard work you know they say don't work
hard work smart
yeah up to a certain point work your ass
off work hard and then once like you've
lifted the boulder up the mountain then
you can start working smart you can't
just start working smart if you have no
work ethic and no money so sometimes
just got to put in the work whatever it
is yeah i mean i guess it's that whole
participation trophy thing which has
sort of ruined the younger generation
and everyone is sort of entitled and
thinks you know things should just come
to them and why do i have to work hard
can't you know the government give me a
loan to start investing in my company
and the government i'm i'm not speaking
on behalf of me that's for sure by the
way i wore this
for you why because it's the colors oh
it's a bitcoin thank you
yeah well it's a bit yellow but
it's a good color i don't have what is
it bitcoin orange yes yeah orange i
apologize no you're good okay so yeah
you know what you're talking about is
very much um the modern day entrepreneur
right that's what you're talking about
um so how do you get into that mindset
because i think a lot of people um are
afraid to leave that nine to five um you
know maybe they've built up capital so
how do you switch that mindset well you
don't have to be an entrepreneur you
could also be an intrapreneur what is
that i'm familiar with that i've heard
it but okay so
i'm actually an entrepreneur i've never
started a business that's not my mo i'm
a networker i'm a sales guy like they
send me out to hunt and bring in leads
and make contacts and make friends and
make connections and make all sorts of
um you know
putting fluttering out there that my
know your skill set i think
like you don't have to be the person
that puts down the capital that starts
the business that has the idea you can
be the number two guy or you can be the
number three guy or girl or whatever at
your company you don't have to be the
number one something that patrick and i
always talk about is know if you're a
number one or not
okay so
you could be a number four you could be
at a fortune 500 company and be a number
eight and have an amazing exit you don't
have to be the number one i learned that
i'm not
like my best skill set is not the number
one because i don't want to deal with
overhead i want to enjoy my weekends i
don't want to have the stress
like there's certain like just certain
traits that an entrepreneur has to have
like you're familiar with the iceberg
effect
like a lot of people only see the top
yes of the success like the money the
cars the women the whatever it is they
don't see the bottom half of the glacier
the iceberg that's the hard work the
perseverance the late nights the
rejections all that stuff and whether
you're an entrepreneur an entrepreneur
you're still going to deal with that but
the entrepreneur shout out to the
entrepreneurs out there they lay it all
on the line
okay like if your business fails
they fail
right if you're an entrepreneur you have
a business within the business so
whether or not like in my financial firm
i don't own the firm i'm the top sales
guy
but i don't have overhead i don't have
staff i don't have underwriters i don't
have to pay the taxes i don't have to
pay the rent like that's not my like i
don't want to deal with that i want to
crush it i want to make money take my
commissions i'm out
so if you find yourself saying well i
don't know what i want to do like i
don't want to do the nine to five thing
but i don't know if i'm cut out to be an
entrepreneur you can there's a middle
ground called the intrapreneur that um
you can build the business and work you
know side by side with the ceo founder
what have you and be the entrepreneur so
you don't need to again quit your nine
to five or take out a loan from the
government or whatever you can just find
a business that you align with and go
crush it with that person and by the way
like the most one of the more famous
entrepreneurs of all time is steve
ballmer steve ballmer microsoft bill
gates hello still steve ballmer is the
top 20 richest people in the world right
now he owns la clippers he was never the
ceo he's never the founder he was i mean
he might at one point been the ceo but
he didn't start the company he wasn't
the number one so he was an entrepreneur
who grew look at um
uh apple uh tim uh
what i'm like losing i'm having a trump
moment tim tim apple tim
tim
tim tim cook yeah thank you gideon
gideon there you go
amazing producer like you remember when
trump was like i'm here with tim apple
and he's like i didn't say tim apple
he's like no we caught it on camera
you're not talking about he said to him
apple i haven't seen that anyway
tim apple didn't found
tim cook didn't found apple right right
but he worked his way up so
uh the new um person at google the new
person at twitter like well we'll see
what happens with elon yeah but all
these people they don't have to found
the company you don't have to be the
number one entrepreneur you can work
your way up and you know nothing's gonna
happen no i think that's a great advice
actually um i think that makes a lot of
sense it's important to know what your
skill sets are and um
work and like monetize that and focus on
that but your content is changing a
little bit right so you're initially
talking about finance but i've noticed
you're speaking a lot with the guys from
fresh and fit you've had rolo who i
recently had on the show you've spoken a
lot with him um talking a lot about
dating and everything like that um so
talk to me about
what you're trying to do why are you
talking about dating and how why are you
interested in that as opposed to finance
yeah well it's thank you the
number one i think it's just more
interesting it is interesting i like i
enjoyed a lot more but
um i think there's
a need for both
and i think there's a need for someone
who understands both
right like so for instance rolo good
friend he understands intersectional
dynamics better than anyone in the world
but he's not a money guy right fresh and
fit shout out to those guys they crush
it they interview tons of women
um they're not money guys you know they
they they're learning myron especially i
think he's investing more in real estate
fresh is more buying like jewelry and
cars more power to you but there's not a
lot of money guys out there talking
about relationships because for any guys
out there
like why are you making money okay so on
the surface so you can pay your bills
but then like once you're past the bills
you know they say that the most people
need to make 75 000 a year to be quote
unquote happy we can have a whole
conversation of what happiness is but
um once you reach a certain level
why are you making all this money
uh to keep up with the joneses to have a
nice car to impress women what's like
your motivating factor to having this
money because it's not just like yeah
bro i made more money than you it's like
what like a competitive situation with
your boys a lot of times you need money
to
uh take out women and women
if there's one underlying theme with
women women like to have fun like cyndi
lauper girls just want to have fun i
think that's very true girls just want
to have fun whether that's with a rich
guy whether that's a broke guy who's
good looking whether that's with a cool
guy like whether it's a funny guy like
why do you think funny guy's comedian i
used to do stand-up comedy i used to get
girls when i was broke as [ __ ] because i
was funny right girls want to have fun
the the the other side of that is
having fun costs money mm-hmm going on
trips costs money going to nice dinners
costs money going to freaking disneyland
costs money like going out costs money
so
you know the intersection where i say is
like my show sas cast is where romance
meets finance right
where money and relationships meet
because there's an intersection right
there like show me like you know i'm
sure there's a lot of crypto people out
there there's some nerds out there that
not in that crypto people are nerds but
that have made a lot of money whether
it's drop shipping social media but they
just sit at a computer all day i don't
care how much money they have they're
never going to go out there into the
real world and meet a beautiful woman or
you know conversely a guy whatever and
what you're into but
it you need both okay so that it's it's
very interesting to me and i think a lot
of men especially young men really need
help these days when i was growing up
let me tell you something leia back in
the day in the in the 90s early 90s you
had to have [ __ ] balls
why because you needed to pick up the
phone a landline
dial the number her father will pick up
the father would pick up and hey can i
speak with britney who's this
this is adam from her class what do you
want from her
i gotta talk to her about homework i'm i
don't it wasn't homework
hold on right and you're
you're dealing with the [ __ ] father
knowing that you're calling to take his
daughter out so you had to maneuver
like in a totally different way that
exists today today you get a girl's
snapchat instagram whatever just dm them
hey what up you up whatever
that's a lot different than when guys my
age late 30s early 40s had to go out and
quote unquote hunt so men these days
they have it very easy in certain ways
you just get a girl's instagram slide in
the dm but that doesn't mean you have
game in real life that doesn't even know
how to like maneuver when the father
shows up or whether that's a metaphor
for whatever hurdle gets thrown your way
so uh you know rollo talks about the
lost boy generation that men aren't
being men anymore because a lot of times
it's too easy they expect overnight
results they don't want to put in the
work this goes back to work ethic so you
know i i i believe as being the oldest
millennial
are you a millionaire yeah the oldest
monster yeah were you born 1981 right so
the
i'm the youngest millennial you're what
year 96 okay so like we're i'm the
oldest you're the youngest so
being the oldest millennial it's
actually a term if you're born in 1980
or something 78 to 82 you're what's
called a zenial you're on the fringe of
gen x and millennials right you can if
you grow up a little too soon you might
be a gen xer if you took a while to grow
up like a miami party boy like me you
might be more of a millennial but you
understand what it was like when you had
to dial the phone and get her girls like
on the phone you know her father picks
up so you understand the difference of
what was going on in the 90s before
social media but you also have a good
grasp on what's going on now so
gen z on the other hand
they've never had to have land lines or
deal with any of the hurdles that comes
with all that stuff everything's at a
press of a button so i think i have a
unique
knowledge like a new unique skill set
that kind of bridges like the old school
mentality and the new school mentality
because a lot the what's the whole
knockout hey what's up boomer
your average 60 year old isn't going to
understand that whereas your average 18
year old has no idea what it was like in
the 90s
and look what year did the iphone out
really come out
like what year did it really make a
splash i was in school we had the
blackberry first and then with the cars
yeah we all blackberries 2000 and
no it was later i think like 2011
everyone really got an iphone that's
when we switched yeah late 2000s from
what i recall like 2007 2008 think about
that so 15 years ago we didn't have any
of what we have now no social media i
mean people weren't on the internet but
it was like
like maybe you're on aol like in some
weird room or like
you know or but it's just so new
and it's just we don't know what the
future's gonna hold but i feel like you
know if you don't understand history
you're doomed to repeat it so
you know there there's a there's a
certain knowledge base that you have if
you're in your late 30s early 40s that
maybe someone doesn't have in their
early 20s or certainly someone who's
kind of like missed the boat like i have
friends who are in their early 40s mid
40s
that dude they got no clue what's going
on with social media they completely
missed the boat so the older you know
older millennials late 30s early 40s the
ones that capitalized on social media
they're killing the game right now
whereas people maybe a year too older
than them they're like i don't know all
that
they're lost in the sauce they're still
maybe on facebook and that's it
so it's a learning curve so your podcast
is would you say it's sort of to empower
men and teach men how to have game how
to do better in in today's dating scene
i think that's part of it especially
because i'm not like the expert on that
i have a lot of expertise in that i grew
up in
miami and south beach i've owned bars
club promoter the whole thing i've been
around women like my entire life but
that's not what i've dedicated my life
to
business-wise socially yeah i know as
much as anyone you've mentioned i've
been out and partied more than any of
them and i can the pop culture scene
that i've been in because of south beach
and because of my inroads in the nba
is like
way like way
further advantage than a lot of people
that talk about this but some like
someone like rolo writes books about
this stuff so i have people like him on
my show and a panel
so as an example i'll have a feminist on
um a housewife a intersexual dynamics
expert like rolo fresh and fit on and
like have them all debate and i'm there
just to kind of curate answers and i
don't like my my whole like i'm very
chameleon-like
like i could be
funny and like cool and chill or i could
be like you know listen [ __ ]
like you know here's the deal like i can
kind of go with the flow and that's what
goes back to the power of networking is
understanding like who you are in the
social dynamic structure but on my show
i'm more of like a host willing to
understand all sides rather than kind of
like there's people that this is my
opinion and i can just go on hours for
that that's not me so what have you
learned what is some of the biggest
problems in the dating scene right now
um
the the number one thing that comes to
mind has to do with women um and
understanding what has changed because
of feminism and this was not something
that i was aware of a year ago and it's
something that i talk about all the time
is that
um you know a stat came out recently and
fact checked this all you want 45
percent of working women between the
ages of 25 and 45 right by the year 2030
so in eight years from now 45 of women
are going to be non-married and
childless
okay
so
women
that have been empowered by feminism and
that's awesome work make your money your
equal all that love women like
women are the number one and this is
going to be controversial the number one
commodity in the world i don't mean that
like in a like
in like a possession type of way
diamonds jewels you know gold bracelet
women are the number one thing people go
to wars over women okay so i respect
women i love women like 100
but women have to understand what their
role is in society
for
millions of years
there was the hunter-gatherer society
and the women was raising the house
raising the children taking care of the
home being a good mother the most
important role of a woman is to be a
mother born on full stop but now
women can make money you know in 1980
there was a movie that came out working
nine to five dollar part you've seen
that working not too fast like that
whole thing
and
like that sparked very much a
feminine revolution i can make my money
i can do my own thing okay great and i'm
not saying that all women you know are
monetized sexually but a large swath of
them are so now we talked about the
barriers to entry look at only fans now
i can't tell you how many girls i meet
that do only fans really i've never met
a girl that doesn't oh my god i mean
you've been to miami once or twice
they're out there okay
and like and they're not gonna just come
out and say hey what do you do for work
i do only fans like well you know i
model i do whatever
but interesting the more money that a
woman makes so they talk about this all
the time guys don't care how much
money a woman makes i had this
conversation with a girl that i'm kind
of talking to these days she's like yeah
you know i um
i'll tell you a story so uh we were at
um this was last week
um there was a big event in miami called
rolling loud you familiar with that huge
hip-hop festival
and travis scott was at the after party
at a place called 11.
familiar with that i've heard of it okay
so
we go there and um
i get us in there's six of us group good
like i know the guy we're good you know
networking the power of networking like
we're good there's a huge line outside
we get in the girls are like super
impressed like that was awesome so we go
in
and um
the girl goes let's go take out a
thousand dollars and make it rain
i go well your money or her money well
right so i go okay where are we going to
get this a thousand dollars and there's
like an atm type it's like a teller it's
not like like a normal atm you go to
like the
strip club teller uh to take the money
out she goes okay go go and i'm like
i'm taking the money out you're the one
that wants to take the money out this is
the girl you're dating no like a girl
that like i was hanging out like a
friend like a girl like red flag bro
yeah well that's what my nickname for
her um
that's your nickname red flag i'm not
even joking so i say um
well no i'm not taking out like no i'm
good by the way it's like five in the
morning i'm ready to go home anyway
and she goes well let's just do 500.
and i go well i'll tell you what
whatever you take out
i'll take out
look at that so whatever you want to
do
i'll do
but like meet me halfway don't just
expect the guy this is a problem so some
guys they're either going to be too
broke to go consider taking out a
thousand dollars some guys are going to
just be like
well she's really hot and my only way to
you know ingratiate myself with this
girl is proving to her that i can do
this or there's some guys that are like
yeah i have the money but i'm not doing
[ __ ] like like that's not was she hot
yeah
late twenties okay so but the point is
this when i was like well why don't you
go take out half and i'll take it off
she's like no you know whatever and then
we got into a whole conversation oh god
about um well we we
you know we gotta take care of these
girls
you know and i was like what do you mean
take care of these these are strippers
and
fast forward she does only fans okay so
there's this mindset that like girls
they're doing it they take care of other
girls whatever i was like yeah i don't
that's not my thing at all
like you do realize that my entire
brand is save that money for these exact
type instances she goes no i get it i
get it
i'm like but back to my point women are
making more money than ever by the way
this girl lives in a sick place she's
making a ton of money i'm sure she has
more than
one only fan if you know what i mean
like she's doing very well but i don't
like the difference between a man and a
woman so let's say i make a half a
million dollars a year
um and let's say a girl makes a hundred
grand a year or even a half a million
dollars a year for that matter
the guy's gonna be let's say we live
together we go the guy's paying for
pretty much everything paying the rent
we go on vacation i'm taking care of the
vacation if we're going for dinners i'm
paying for dinners like i'm not asking
you to do anything correct other than
just be pretty and pleasant and have a
good time and have a great attitude
whereas the girl
whatever she makes she's not spending on
the guy
so
you asked like the initial like dating
relationships like guys need to
understand
how this works with their money
right so most like fresh and fit always
talk about this like i don't care what a
girl does they say that i'm like no i
care what she does but i don't care like
like the amount of money she makes
because she's not spending that on me
it's a guy's role to spend it on her so
and you agree with me i agree with you
yeah how do you agree with me ask me a
more specific question so do you like
why do you agree that guys spend the
money and girls don't spend the money on
the guy well i mean i personally value
traditional gender roles right okay um
and so i enjoy the fact like i think
that's what men should do and i think
that okay because like because i agree
with you when you said
that i think the most beautiful thing a
woman can do is be a mother and
raise children and have a family
and
excuse this term but serve her husband
right like i personally think that
that's sort of how um so
serve as in
like
make his life um as easy as possible
right because he's the one that's paying
for everything um and my brother's in
the room and we were talking about this
earlier today gideon goes gideon goes i
just want my woman to cook me bacon and
eggs and i'll pay for everything all i'm
asking is for bacon and eggs in a clean
house and it's true is it that hard to
ask for them
because i think it's true look if he's
going to pay for everything then why are
you upset and i did this video the other
day and the video was saying um
you know men go out to work every single
day um and women are trying to complain
and compete and all he's asking is you
know
relax stay home please just be a
nurturing mother i will pay for
everything and um women got really
offended because they said that it's not
relaxing to be
a mother right have you ever had a child
layer it's hard to take care of a child
i'm sure but i can tell you as someone
that's got a business that it's that i
imagine it's harder to be an
entrepreneur than it is to be a mother
having an entrepreneur having
responsibilities like that having to
make that money without um you know
because you don't know how you're gonna
live the next day there's nobody else to
pay your bills i'm the only one that
pays my own bills um you know and so
that's very stressful and i think that's
more stressful than raising children and
having a man that will that will
guarantee a roof over your head and a
financial system sorry not a financial
system a judiciary system which will
guarantee that right because if you get
divorced then don't worry you've got the
kid and the money so you literally have
it all sorted as a woman basically do
you think it's um
easier these days to be a man or a woman
i think it's oh okay so i
i somewhat do think it's 50 50. um
i think if you're a high value man which
is you know like
rich successful um you know you've got
game you're exciting you're fun you're
smart you're intelligent you're strong
right the whole usual spill i think if
you're that then you own the world right
um i think
what makes you a high-value woman in the
red-peeled world will go down that that
route um is young and beautiful and
sweet and all that but that that can't
last so at least like men can
you know because people age right so men
have control over their over their
sexual market value whereas women don't
have control because time ticks on so
that's why i think it's easier to be a
man although i do understand that men
have to become and women can just be
i respect that and i get that
but
i think given the fact that you can
actually do something about your value
as a man makes it easier to be a man
what do you think
well
by the way there's no clear-cut answer
but i'll give you my opinion this by the
way this is way more exciting than just
talking about investing in 401ks well we
do it all i'm just saying like this this
is the reason that this type of um
content i think is so um valuable
because there's so many different
opinions on this there's not a lot of
different opinions on finance i get
should you do in stock market you should
do real estate but like you know but
so what i always say is yeah it's
[ __ ] hard to be a guy i'm sure right
so like
it took me multiple years 10 years to go
from broke as a joke you know to having
money to being a quote unquote high
value whatever the hell that term you
know signifies but having money like
being successful having game women the
whole thing
what percentage of men get to that point
maybe 10 okay
but at least a man knows what he needs
to do like my whole thing is clarity no
matter what situation i just need some
clarity like help me get clear on what
we're trying to establish here and for a
man it's very clear make money you know
be good looking be a gentleman be suave
like be good to your lady be good to
your mom like have what sauce like have
a little bit of like so i mean that's
literally my name sauce
like have a little something going on
like but that's not easy to do but again
clarity you know what the [ __ ] you got
to do like
run that way run through the wall kick
ass and if you work hard enough and if
your mindset is right you'll get there
cool so for a man it's hard but at least
there's clarity the problem with women
is that there's a lack of clarity should
you be a boss babe an empowered woman
and like i don't need no man kind of
vibe or should you be a housewife
reliant on a man raising kids being a
good mother and a being a good wife
which one
well you're going to have half of women
saying one thing and having half of
women saying the other whereas you have
pretty much 100 of men saying kick ass
make money have success so which one is
it if you're looking for clarity it's
much easier to be a man
right
but for a woman
you know
it's
flip a coin as to what you should do the
angel tater i know you've interviewed
and we're working on getting him on
valuetainment we're in discussions right
now
he tells this story and i think it's so
true because i've been on these types of
parties
uh these yacht parties where there's
four guys and a hundred women
and he tells the story he's like you
show me a yacht right and there's four
guys on this yacht all right and a
hundred women
and there is no telling what these four
men had to do what kind of contribution
to society they had how much work ethic
they needed to have how much people they
needed to employ and impress and deals
and wheeling and dealing and maybe by
the time they're 60 [ __ ] years old
they get to kick back relax halfway bald
and fat probably by the way but at least
enjoy the spoils of the luxury of their
labor whereas you have a hundred women
who are 20 to 30 years old and all they
had to go do was buy some [ __ ]
lipstick hey i've never been on a yacht
okay well you're how do i get on here
i've not been on a yacht how is that
even possible i've not been on new york
because you're a boss babe you're not
just using your sexuality to
what's a boss babe well like a working
woman a woman who's like making you know
her own money
never heard that
like i've heard it but i think boss babe
has really negative connotations
i agree well babe is like boss babe is
like i'm a boss [ __ ] i don't need no
man like [ __ ] men like that's not me i
agree i mean i agree with you however
making your own money and making carving
your own niche in this world is you
but i just think that's human survival
you think so who else is going to pay my
bills
well according to a lot of women out
there a man
which one
well you got to find i mean i'm on it
i gotta have somewhere to live do i live
on the streets and to do i will get a
sugar daddy no i don't want that yeah a
lot of women do i know her own money so
she can get to the great places where
the men are yeah let's talk about this
let's talk about this i like gideon kind
of being a great uh segway over there
wait one thing you didn't mention i
don't know if they can i hope you guys
can hear him
speaking this
if the man makes one million dollars
he's willing to spend it all on his girl
to protect her provide her if the woman
makes a million dollars she will not
spend a dime she'll keep it all in the
bank that's a huge point yeah that's
what you were saying that's what you
yeah exactly
that's what you were saying and i think
um that is true um that's 100 true um
once you get into that relationship um
but what you you ask oh yeah so yeah
that that boss babe thing it's
interesting because i come from a small
little town just outside of london right
and i can
you know get a secretary job and just
work a nine-to-five and not make a lot
of money but it means i'm stuck in that
situation where everyone's fat and gray
and old right so there's no high value
men or women right nobody cares about
anything in that situation right okay so
i'm like so what do i need to do
to let's say meet a man that i think
would be equal value to me or you know
someone that i would like and be happy
with well i'm sure you discussed this
before but the whole concept of
hypergamy right yeah you did this with
rolo when you're like how much how tall
does a guy need to be yeah how much
money does he need to make what does he
need to bring to the table you know
women will only date across and above
right so men will
they'll bang the hot chick that works at
starbucks or the waitress or whatever or
they'll take
you know the
ceo type girl out there you know the
attractive uh pundit you know type
person out there so
roles are different so right but and
what i'm saying is like everyone from
that town was was was below right so as
a woman i want to date across or up so
everyone was below so now i'm live
right but how do i afford that i got to
make money
and so i make money and i i i did well
and you know things are going well which
is great um but now i'm like apparently
this boss [ __ ] that doesn't need no
money i don't i never called you a [ __ ]
that's just oh sorry
no you have like the difference between
you and those girls is you actually
number one have a good understanding of
the world number two you have a good
attitude a lot of those women have
really horrible attitudes and they kind
of like have a disdain for men and they
just kind of like
they look at men as like a
cash register an atm
and yeah i can't believe this chick is
asking you for a grand
yeah that's awful
yeah well you know
that blows my mind sorry i interrupted
you but yes you were talking about how
uh women have this negative um
relationship towards men yeah well the
the
look you're gonna be okay let me try
what was the initial question though
i don't know it's just going back and
forth at this point we're talking about
feminism why it's gonna mess things up
well the i but this is backs to my whole
point is that women there's a lack of
clarity should you go and find a man and
be a housewife should you carve your own
career i'm an advocate of women getting
their own career like
i don't
i get whether it i don't think it's just
all men working like how annoying is
that just all men what what zero
interaction with females in the world so
i am an advocate of women working but
the whole thing is
like your brother you know so
pointlessly pointed out the women aren't
going to spend their money on the man so
it's the man's job to provide and be the
man and especially in a relationship
um whereas
all the money that women wait makes
you know they spend on themselves it's
hard being a woman you think it's easy
like i've lived with girls okay it's
really hard yeah like you need money to
just to walk out of your house every day
makeup hair nails
clothes like i could have my nails down
this week kind of a guy could roll up
out of bed and just like throw on a
t-shirt like yo what up we're going to
the gym like it's much harder to be a
woman but at the same time it's much
easier to be a woman in certain social
settings like don't forget a lot of my
um
you know the reason that i deal with
money and game and all that just don't
forget i remember being 16 18 20 years
old going out to clubs in south beach
and if i went with three of my buddies
we wouldn't get in
but if i went with three girls i would
get in and be in the vip for official
okay so i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm learning
things here
dudes are kryptonite to a club unless
you're buying bottles unless you're
spending cash right and i've been in
more clubs than probably most people in
this freaking world okay and i haven't
spent a lot of money because i'm again a
great networker i know all the people in
the clubs and the scene like that's just
what i do but
to be a man
like i
i i because i interview a lot of people
and i'll remember i go to people in the
south like guys groups of guys what up
guys like how was your time in south
beach [ __ ] hated here man
we didn't get into any clubs bro yeah
well did you drop loot no we weren't
gonna spend two grand on a table well
it's like
would you want seven dudes in your club
not spending money no no
but seven girls could roll up and
they'll give them a free bottle
just to hang out
so to say that men and women aren't
different in some capacity especially
when it comes to money and sexual market
value would be a complete lie
so
no matter what it is women are going to
bring certain things to the table and
men are going to bring certain things to
the table men are going to have to bring
money to the table a lot of the cases
women are going to have to bring
attractiveness yes fertility and a good
damn attitude yeah i have a story for
you as well um so when i was 20 i'd go
to all the clubs in london and it's the
same vibe right it's like women getting
free promoters bottles notice how
whether it's miami or london or
sydney or hong kong it's the same vibe
100 men spend money women look good boom
but it's [ __ ] and i'll tell you why
because i obviously was living with my
parents at the time and my dad every
time i'd come home in the morning would
be like did you meet any nice guys and
i'm like no dad because you know who's
in this damn club because i have no
money so i'm 20. because so i go there
to get them for free fat old men are in
there i'm 20 i don't want to be i don't
want to be partying with fat old men and
so i'm there with these young girls
we're all having a great time looking
you know our best super youthful and
amazing whatever
and the the waiter that work that he
said to us um
girls we'll give you a free bottle of
champagne if you could just entertain
our clients
and i'm like
you're speaking to like three really
like well-raised jewish girls here we're
not entertaining any of your clients
like we don't need your champagne and
these were like really old fat men that
wanted us to entertain whatever that
meant yeah and we're just like we're
raised way too well for this no um
but
so you know what happens if they weren't
fat and old and they were actually
good-looking guys in their 30s but
they're not that's the thing they know
what are you talking about they never
work
they never were i i went i from i was
like i went to a lot of clubs in london
from like 18 to maybe like 22 and i was
bored um and now i don't go clubbing i
just talk that was what rolo calls your
whole face not that you were putting out
or anything like that i never did i
never did sorry boys no i i i i never
ever did but no i look it's what girls
just want to have fun it's a free time
to cindy love it yeah it's a free time
to dance to some music with your
girlfriends and have a great time um but
no there were never ever ever any
attractive men in there and dad every
time i came home would say meet any nice
guys no dad no maybe it was just a
horrible club because you know i went to
all of them in london pretty attractive
men and women no not in london um
yeah so that's why i'm always like yeah
it's cool you know
you get to go into clubs for free as a
young woman but it's like and but it's
like
the kind of men that that attracts isn't
what you're looking for
because men can't get in
unless they put down a ton of money and
sometimes men don't even want to put
down a ton of money you know and i
understand that why would you like you
said you become a minimalist yeah like
the chances of me spending thousands of
dollars at a club at this point in my
life are so non-existent exactly because
i've already done that
okay so
you know like that
as you grow you learn a lot but you know
this it's just i've been to
clubs you know venues yachts parties
like
you know the whole you know wedding that
i was a part of i don't know if you're
familiar with that whole thing like i've
had experience with the richest of the
richest
and now it's like i just want to be
secure with my own situation so the um
that but you have to learn that as you
grow older like you know
women i feel like 30 is a major age for
women women look at 30
and they
you know i'm 25. i'm freaking out
you're perfect right now
but women you know reach an age at 30
that they kind of like all right
biological clocks tick in like what am i
going to do but men i feel like for most
men that age is 40. when i turned 40 a
year ago i was like what the [ __ ] am i
doing i broke up with my girl i got this
guy i got no it's got you like so men
and women age differently so i learned
that from none other than kim kardashian
by the way
what did you what happened well when she
was 30 yeah um she was dating my best
friend at the time well still one of my
best friends wait i know nothing about
pop culture but having spent um some
time in miami earlier this year
um is that the really tall guy yeah yeah
what's his name his name is chris
humphries uh he was at a gemini party i
went to i had no idea someone just
pointed him out to me and i was like oh
okay at the uh winklevoss yes yeah we
were at the same party had i noticed i
bumped into you yeah he was at the
podium you were drunk great memory i was
not drunk there was hot guys there
why that
that one tyler and cameron winklevoss
were there tyron county yeah that they
were if miami was there he's also
attractive yeah okay yeah well anyway i
was there with him and like that crew
um
so yeah
well
as the story goes
um
so i used to be a pretty good basketball
player like i played college football a
little college basketball
uh and i used to network a lot with a
lot of nba guys and um i used to play
basketball with that guy chris humphries
back in the day and actually minneapolis
where my mom is from in the summers uh
we kept in touch when he came down to
miami he made it to the nba he was 19.
he couldn't get into any of the clubs so
he would call me we would get him into
the club i don't think there's any like
uh statue of limitations like getting an
underage person in the club in uh 2004
but they're going to come for you
they're going to come for me so we'd get
we'd party together uh we went from
being like friends to good friends to
one of his best friends and
fast forward the guy's six nine he's
made 50 million in the nba he's a good
looking dude like if he ever tries to
give me like i remember this one i'll
tell the kim kardashian store but chris
would always tell
all right guys like this is advice to
like how you should pick up chicks and i
go dude shut the [ __ ] up
don't even talk anymore you're six nine
you're good looking dude you're worth 50
million don't tell all the rest of us
your advice
like save it that's like if like giselle
bunchen walked in she's like ladies
listen this is how you land a high value
man it's like you're a goddamn
supermodel you have to stand there and
look good save it anyway
so chris calls me one day
out of the blue and he goes what up
um
say what's up to my girl she goes hey
what's up adam what's going on you know
we're coming down to miami next week i
go who is this she goes it's kim silly
i'm like
kim who
it's kim kardashian like i'm like is
this like and it sounds like her right
i'm like what is happening right now i
gotta throw chris back on the phone i go
dude who are you with right now he's
like dude just like play cool like yeah
turns out it was kim kardashian
and um they had this fairytale romance
she was 30 years old back to my entire
beginning point she had just turned 30
and she was quote unquote freaking out
that she wasn't married yet and she was
dating my boy and my boy's got a move
where he tells a girl i love you within
like the first 10 minutes hey i think i
love you like most people probably take
a year to tell a girl that right
that's like his move and they boom fall
in love
get engaged the whole deal
i like i take a year out of my life to
be a kardashian i'm not even kidding
like we fly to mexico together we're on
trips together i'm staying at kim's
house in la beverly hills like and
we do this whole wedding they fly us out
uh
zenya tuxedos the whole like the whole
thing like i'm walking khloe kardashian
down the aisle like the whole thing like
google it whatever but like i'm thinking
we're friends i didn't know that yeah
well this is why you ask these questions
on podcasts but so this whole thing
happens
and i'm like like
friends are hitting me up like dude you
know kim karda like what is happening
right now right
and
boom like that like they divorce after
like 72 days
and
i called her
because we were friends like she's my
age 41 years old um currently
and she
and i go kim like uh
what happened
she goes you know you know i was in a
hurry to get married
because we've had these conversations
before because chris is five years
younger than me chris is 37 years 36
years or whatever he is
um
she goes yeah i just i kind of rushed
into it she's like there's not a phone
call and i go well best of luck i hope
like the next wedding works out better
for you genuinely and she goes oh honey
i'm the modern day elizabeth taylor i'll
probably be married a dozen times
her words i swear to god and elizabeth
taylor i think was married like eight or
nine times now kim has
gone through i don't know
[Music]
kanye
she's gonna chew this guy pete davidson
out like he'll move on to something else
you'll see what's gonna happen with this
girl but back to my initial point this
all really stemmed because she was 30
and freaking out
so um but there is some validity to that
because if we go back to my initial
point before that
you know
45 percent of women are going to be
non-married and no kids by the time
they're 20 30.
and if like your goal of a woman is to
get married and have kids you need to
reassess what you're doing with your
life because men don't care about your
job description or much money you make
they care about different things so on
that point and i think this might be my
final question on that point then um
something i'm really curious about
i think this is i think the answer is
different for different men um so let's
get your take does it put you off um
whether a woman is um successful um and
also what she does for work right um
because of course it's different if
she's like the ceo and suited and booted
of this company i get that's kind of
off-putting um but yeah does it put you
off if a woman has money
no i don't think it puts you off so um
because i get you don't care that's fine
no i because i do care i i'll tell you
not about the money about what they do
i've dated i've never dated a woman
who's more successful than me okay even
when i didn't have money i dated a girl
like we were both just kind of like in
our 20s figuring things out but
well a lot of the girls i tend to date
are younger and that whole thing but
um
[Music]
i i don't care like i just want a woman
who can actually just pay her own bills
because nothing is worse than having
like kind of a leech of a girl that
can't pay her own bills
so
um
some guys are okay with that like like a
woman should have something she's
definitely passionate about because
like to just expect a woman to just sit
home and all day and take care of the
kids and the family and make sandwiches
is
really undermining of the value of a
woman a woman should have something that
they're passionate about i don't care if
that's yoga or bitcoin or you know
pick a thing photography something that
like drives them that motivates them but
also you know at the same time
congruently taking care of the family
taking care of a man
women have gone down this path where
they need to be educated they need to
make money you know whether they believe
it or not don't need a man because they
can pay their own bills
um where does that end where does that
and where do they end up i'll tell you a
story that
really resonated to me on my 40th
birthday
um at bodega here
not here but you know in bodega and down
in miami um
the uh
it was my 40th birthday and all my
friends were there and
um
i was single i'd recently broken up with
a girl and my boy shows up
um miguel
and he goes yo what up salsa where are
you bro you're killing it bro you're 40
now you got money you're looking good
bro you're killing it valuetainment like
like dude you're killing it bro i'm so
proud of you i'm like yo thank you
brother he goes oh [ __ ]
is that laura over there who we went to
high school with i go yeah he goes
what's up with her again same age i go
yeah yeah she's doing good she married
yet bro
no
uh she got kids no i don't think so man
what's she up to i'm like yeah she's
still working he goes damn that sucks
and i go oh damn there it is
like if you ever need a case example i
learned it on my 40th birthday where i
like spent the minute being like
damn poor laura over there where adam 40
successful high value whatever
but like he's like dude you're the
[ __ ] man
and her he she's like what happened to
her because she was like the hottest
thing in high school and a lot of times
women
will
you know
in their 20s what i haven't got nothing
to lose i'm all good 26. cool
guys are coming at me i'm 30. okay i'm
kind of freaking out a little bit now
but i'm still 30 and i'm making money
next thing you know you're 35 and the
guys who were approaching you
now they're more approaching the new
batch of 21 25 year old chicks and
you're kind of like you're still hot
you're 35
but next thing you know you're 40 and
you're laura
and
the guys that pursued you before
they're like yeah yeah i'm good like
i'll take new laura who's 10 years
younger because guys care about
guys are visual whereas women aren't as
visual creatures um so i i'll never
always tell that story about my friend
by the way her real name is laura
because i don't want to put her [ __ ] out
there like that um and i always remember
like okay 40 year old adam
pimp stud doing his thing 40 year old
laura
went went sad story and i feel bad
because lawyer is awesome
but
laura
you know probably should have doubled
down on a dude who
was in love with her 10 years prior but
she was like i'll do better
and then that that prince charming never
came around yeah it breaks my heart yeah
i see it in your face you're like no it
hurts me it breaks my heart became a
dead flower kid stop is that what
happened it doesn't break let me know
let me ask you a question
careful with your questions do you think
how much time i have we have like 10
minutes okay do you think
genuine question mm-hmm that you'll ever
meet a man you love
as much as you love bitcoin
i bloody well hope so yeah that's like
man before bitcoin for sure really yeah
how do i come across like come across as
like this hard
yeah
clarify what you want in a man yeah like
i i like for me like
i want to be a wife why like i don't
understand everyone's so surprised every
time i say that i'm not surprised i'm
just i like i feel like you love
bitcoin
yeah i don't think like bitcoins look
bitcoin's not giving me children and
it's not like being it's not holding me
at night is it no maybe i hold my
bitcoin i need something to huddle me
maybe your bit max account maybe you're
just like oh that's so weird adam that's
so not cool no so you think you that you
could put a man before bitcoin i know i
could put a man before bitcoin oh for
sure i put a man before a lot of things
yeah i just unfortunately haven't met
anyone that i'm in love with like i've
i've loved but i haven't like
been like wow
like you are somebody that i want to
give my future to i think love is giving
a future to someone and i haven't met
anyone that i want to give my future to
and that i have been in relationships
and i and i've broke
them off
because i'm like you're not the one that
i want to marry and i don't want to
waste time um and i'm looking for the
one that i want to marry 100
yeah i think um i say this all the time
men you should waste your 20s as much as
possible agreed waste your 20s like i
wasted my 20s zero regrets
women can waste their early 20s yeah do
not waste your mid-20s because if you
waste your mid-20s you're going to wake
up one day and you're going to be 30
and you're going to be like the kim
kardashian story and you're just going
to marry the first guy that tells you he
loves you and that's not going to work
out well so men and women are different
but i appreciate women beyond
um but like they they they need to
understand
like the future like you said uh you
said so eloquently like i i put my
future how did you describe that
love is giving someone else your future
yeah it's amazing yeah and i just
haven't met anyone that i want to give
my future to yet
um you know and it means giving up many
different things which are we don't need
to get into what do you mean get into
them i'd rather not on my project but
we're not
this podcast from what i understand is
where the conversations that nobody
wants to have other places your party
takes place we can have them on the
sauce cast podcast okay i'll come on
your podcast i'll come back into the
studio and we'll have like comments on
bitcoin we'll have this awkward
conversation we'll have this awkward
conversation what is the point of
contention here right now put in like
the point of contention that you won't
answer what
the setting the setting their time in
and we can speak about that offer okay
all right i think i'm going to end it
there adam i want to thank you so much
for coming on it's been a lot of fun
um i really appreciate your insight on
finance you had a lot to say
i love this conversation um i love
everything you've done and major
congrats on moving and shifting and
everything that you're building um
it's great to have you on it guys please
follow adam's cast podcast valuetainment
they're doing amazing on youtube
um i give a plug please go go follow us
on valuetainment and then my channel is
called valuetainmentmoney um and we've
got a lot of exciting things that are
coming up right now with some new talent
that we're signing an a-list hollywood
actor is now coming to valuetainment uh
one of the ladies jedediah bila she just
left well she was on the view
she's now on valuetainment and we've got
a bunch of surprises that are coming up
we're doing a major event in south
florida you know uh
x amount of uh 100 000 miles that way um
and uh we're gonna have robert kiyosaki
there and a bunch of uh
chas palmitari a bunch of uh kevin
connolly amazing
um amazing things and uh so follow us on
valuetainment and you can follow my
personal channel on
saucetalksmoney
on instagram and by the way just to just
free plug for you for me for everyone
there's a lot of fake accounts out there
for mine i've i've gotten hit up by
multiple leia halliburtons don't give
anybody crypto because they dm'd you
yeah anybody
that's my problem with the crypto these
days like there's a lot of scammers out
there but that's a whole other topic
don't send anybody money just because
they dm you yeah no thank you for saying
that actually uh because a very good
friend of mine um just got scammed at
400 because they thought it was me so
that's problematic but adam thank you so
much um and guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you found this valuable
and also don't forget um if you do want
to buy the dip right now then bitmex is
the place to go a huge thank you to
bitmakes because without them we
wouldn't be able to bring you such
important content and while you're here
please don't forget to hit the subscribe
button and the like button and we'll see
you all next week the leia hill pen show
you